England arrived with belief rather than
fair
but France are formidable as the world
cup holders and they showed why with
immediate attacking threat and an
Olivier Giroud header
France were given the space to create
chances and many took advantage from
distance
a shot place with power and precision
that couldn't be stopped for the first
time in Qatar England were trailing
Harry Kane searched for an equalizer
that came early in the second half after
picaya Saka was brought down
and the captain converted from the spot
scoring a 53rd England goal a record
shared with Wayne Rooney relief for fans
at home with renewed hope
but it was France who took the lead
again
through giroud's head
England had a reprieve with another
penalty after a foul or Mason mount
this time though Kane missed the target
[Applause]
penalty heartache even without a
shootout
the hurt continues for England 56 years
and counting
the title defense goes on for France
into a semi-final with Morocco you know
we got nowhere near uh before so then we
have to stick with Southgate um and I
think he's the man to lead the song I
think we've got to go foreign as much as
I've really enjoyed Southgate what he's
done and brought everyone together and
the you know I think someone like too
sure someone like you know a
mourinho-esque you know someone that can
has one trophy someone who's got that
tactical Mouse the last two tournaments
we've done well even this tournament
we've done well the top goal scorers
right so
it's disappointing
but we can take positives overcoming the
world champions prove Beyond this
talented England group but with so many
heavyweights already knocked out of this
tournament this will be seen as a big
missed opportunity as England fell short
on a decade-long mission to win the
World Cup in 2022. this is an English
side that can match the best but still
not deliver when it matters most
it's Journey's End in Qatar Gara
Southgate will now decide on the right
decision for his and the team's future
Rob Harris Sky News Al hor in Qatar